so drew brees comes back and he's
practically picked a better week to do
so come back get the kansas city cheese
how worried do we need to be right now
about brees headed into the playoffs
based on the way that he played
yesterday
well i looked at him yesterday and he
didn't look good he looked hesitant
he didn't look 100 confident and he just
looked like he he didn't have a good
feel for the game so if i'm sean payton
as much as i love drew brees and and i'm
a guy i've
played with drew brees i've known drew
brees for a long time and the thing
about drew brees is he'll do anything he
can to get back on that football field
he'll give his left arm so when you're
sean payton when you're asking drew
brees are you a hundred percent or can
you play of course he's going to say yes
but it's up to the coach to kind of you
know tailor things back and say hey man
you know we're going to keep you out one
more week and we're going to allow
tayson to take some to go out there and
play for us
i'm not big on the two quarterback
approach but this may be a special
circumstance here where i think the two
quarterback approach may work as they
get into the playoffs
he's just not throwing the ball like he
once did brees i mean he loaded into one
this is the best defensive game plan
that i've seen against the saints they
sat so hard on all those underneath
routes to start the game especially
camara i mean casey was just playing
everything so close to the line of
scrimmage and taking away all the easy
throws that brees loved so much and then
when he loaded it up i mean he just took
a double crow op into one let it go and
it went about 45 yards and i understand
he's got about 15 broken ribs that he's
battling through but it went about 45
yards and it was a little under thrown
and amanda sanders caught the ball down
the field but if i'm a defensive
coordinator i would live with that all
day rodney i don't know about you i
would play up around the line i'm just
daring them to throw one of those up
one-on-one i'll take my chances with
that all day long playing the saints
team right now absolutely jack and i
think that's the defensive game plan
moving forward these defensive
coordinators they watch tape they talk
they communicate and once they see that
guys are sitting down forcing drew brees
to throw the ball down the field trying
to take away alvin kamara out of the
backfield and you know one guy that i
just continue to look at is just derek
cook i think he could really be
outstanding and i know over the years a
lot of people have said this why can't
this guy go to that next level but he is
such a big target um once they get
michael thomas back if they get him back
in the playoffs that's going to really
help drew brees because it doesn't
matter how he's covered he drew brees
always feels like he has an opportunity
to get him the ball so you know once he
gets back that should help the brace you
know it should brace the fall a little
bit for drew brees
it should let's hear from sean payton
let's hear from drew brees after a tough
loss it's so i mean it's just coming
back against kansas city you know you're
gonna have to score 30 plus to go trying
to get a win it's a tough game to come
back with all those broken ribs but here
were coach and quarterback after a close
one
offensively we didn't start real well
and so it's hard to just obviously you
can
point to one position but i felt like
our third down numbers weren't good
enough today
um i didn't feel like we ran the ball
uh efficiently when we tried
um
you know give kansas city credit
um we battled back in the game but
you've got to be better on third down
and when you're not you don't have those
attempts you don't have the
the snaps the time of possession all the
things you need against a
a good offense like that you know we
talk about time of possession in a game
like this and
that that includes converting third down
so overall offensively we weren't very
sharp
i still have a little ways to go i'll be
honest you know um
i think there's
there's uh
there's some things that that you know
i'm still still kind of working on but
um
but
it is what it is
are you 100
no
but jack that's that's my point jack if
you if you're not a hundred percent
if you hold on if you're not a hundred
percent then why are you even out there
on a football field it's not it's to me
it wasn't really fair drew brees and i
love his competitive spirit i love the
fact that he wants to be back out there
but if he's eighty percent and taysom
hill is a hundred percent go with taysom
hill give drew brees another week or so
to get healthy to get more reps into
practice because it
we're so used to drew brees coming back
and all of a sudden he fits right into
offense he's productive he's making
plays but this year is just different
you know he's gotten a little older he's
beat up and i just think that he has to
be more honest with sean payton because
it's not about him at this point in time
it's about the entire team so if you're
not a hundred percent why do you stand
there and i understand i respect the
fact that he's tough as nails and he
wants to be out there for his team but a
80 percent drew brees is not better than
100 taysom hill and then you think about
this and this is my last point sean
payton said our offense wasn't on the
same page it's because when you have
taysom hill and you have drew brees you
have to run two different offenses and
now the players have to adjust to a to
take some hill and the offense that they
run or when drew brees is in there so
of course you're not going to be on the
same page because you have two different
offenses jack
and also taysom hill is a key part of
the offense when brees is playing
quarterback so now taysom hill has to
readjust from being the true full-time
quarterback of the saints to now this
tight end
full back special teams player i mean
they throw him the ball often and then
he still comes in and he runs the
essentially the red zone offense for the
saints where he takes the snap and he's
doing all the read options stuff and
typically he's running the ball in so he
still has all these multiple roles that
he's had
four or so weeks off of that he's trying
to readjust and get back into i just
don't know that new orleans would scare
me very much right now going into the
playoffs especially if they have to go
through green bay with a beat up team
with a beat up drew brees with a beat up
michael thomas
i like green bay a lot in that matchup
especially if it's four degrees outside
and the way aaron rodgers is playing
right now
jack let me tell you something when the
saints lost that number one seed
to phillip that when philadelphia beat
him i was like i just shook my head i
said they blew a golden opportunity
because that's an opportunity to have a
home playoff game to be the number one
seed and have a week off
and
at drew brees age at aaron rodgers age
that week is like an eternity
and you have to appreciate that and it's
not just for the old guys but the young
guys you gotta understand a lot of these
guys are hitting not just a rookie wall
but they're hitting a covet wall i talk
to veteran players i've talked to young
players and they've all said the same
thing i'm tired it's irritating we go
through so much emotional stuff worrying
about who we're around if that person
has covet getting tested every day you
know making sure that we limit our
family interaction those things are
really affecting people so you see a lot
of teams up and down and inconsistent
and i think that's that's a major reason
why because you know guys are getting
burnt out
let's get into two other quarterbacks
have been around this league for a
minute two great quarterbacks matt ryan
had another big lead built over tom
brady i know we've seen this movie
before and all of a sudden brady pulls
out the sequel how did tom get back into
that game this may be the most complete
offensive performance that we've seen
from the bucks all 20 20.
yeah it was so weird man because the
first half it was like time was
completely off and i think that's what
bruce arians was talking about we we
can't go into the playoffs you know
having one half where we look terrible
and then all of a sudden having a half
well we look incredible tom had like 70
yards in the first half and then he came
back and threw for 320 but it's two
things it's experience with tom brady
and his composure because tom when he
struggled in the first half he never
panicked and that's the experience of
tom brady and bruce aaron's know it i
think another um situation they didn't
have their running back they didn't have
their starting running back when you
don't have your start and running back
now you have to go to leonard fournette
who came in and gave them a spark and
gave them some tough running but you
know i just i looked and i was like wow
tom brady still has it now just think if
they could put four quarters together
like that jack this could really be a
dangerous team
you finally it completes not the right
word in the sense of the game but
complete in sense of tom finally finding
all the weapons when when antonio brown
caught that touchdown down the sideline
i one of one of the real standout
moments of that game to me was watching
the hug between brady and a.b that said
everything you need to know about their
relationship and this still looks like
the same antonio brown to me i was
wondering if he would look a step slower
not quite as quick his routes wouldn't
be as crisp he wouldn't have any
chemistry with tom but they have had
such a limited amount of time to work
together and if they get right come
playoff time godwin mike evans had huge
games we've seen gronk stay healthy now
is it the same gronk as he was in his
complete prime in new england maybe not
but he's good for three or four scene
balls a game he's good in the red zone
and if he can just bring a little bit of
that they have enough dynamic playmakers
on the outside and size on the outside
namely mike evans that i think this is
an offense that can get really dangerous
they find that chemistry and find that
flow which they seem to be doing at the
perfect time it's funny it almost feels
like getting behind and having to come
back and just put the ball in brady's
hand and let him go do his thing it
might have been the best thing for this
passing game it might just be that spark
they need running right into the
playoffs
absolutely you talk about gronk and you
make an excellent point because gronk is
at a point in time in his career whereas
he doesn't have to carry the offense
where when he was with new england tom
and he and tom carried the offense now
he has other guys and like you talked
about you make a really good point jack
three or four receptions you know
they're gonna be a couple plays down the
field you know he's gonna run over a
couple guys he's gonna make a statement
he's gonna catch a red zone touchdown
and that's all they need from him you're
going to eventually get ronald jones
back devin white i mean he was
outstanding yet last night on the
football field 12 tackles three sacks if
they can continue to get that type of
performance from the linebackers antoine
whitfield made some plays and even at
the cornerback position where they've
struggled and zone and some man-man
coverage they're at least out there
competing so i like what they're doing
and um like bruce aaron said if they can
put it together jack here in the next
couple weeks playing four quarters going
into the playoffs i don't know many
teams would like to go out and play
against tampa
i agree and the weakness that we've seen
especially is when they played new
orleans new orleans has been the worst
matchup for tampa but it seems to me
like two teams that are trending in
opposite directions seems like tampa is
coming together
they're starting to figure out a rhythm
and a flow and all of a sudden brady
looks like he's been playing with these
guys for five or six years like he
looked like with all of his receivers in
new england
in new orleans looks like they may have
a quarterback controversy heading into
late december so i don't know that i
don't know that i'm a huge believer that
new orleans could do the same kind of
damage that they did to tampa the first
time around
and if they can't i mean it's entirely
possible these two could meet again and
if they did i don't think it's gonna be
that 38 to three or whatever it was kind
of blow out i can't i can't anticipate
that they could do that to brady once
again what do you think why is that such
a tough matchup for this bucks team this
year do you anything in particular that
you think
you know what i think i think what it is
is when you look at um
when you look at the saints front four
they get after you and they did a heck
of a job against patrick mahomes they
got after patrick mahomes i think they
had only like three sacks but trey
hendrickson cameron jordan before he got
kicked out and by the way cameron you
know you can't get kicked out you're the
best player on the defensive side of the
ball you have to stay in the game don't
take the bait but yeah they got after um
they got after patrick mahomes hit them
roughed them up and they were physical
and if you can if you can get after
patrick mahomes and if you can limit the
big plays tyree when i say big plays i'm
talking about 40 50 60 yards down the
field if you keep everything in front of
you and i always say this jack make them
go the long hard way 10 12 14 play
drives forget about three plays and it's
a 65 yard touchdown you have to make
them go the long hard way the defense
played a heck of a lot better and they
were ready to play compared to what they
showed last week again against the
philadelphia eagles so i i still believe
that this is one of the top defenses in
the league one of the top five defenses
in the league that won't change my mind
and i think they can bring a lot of
positive encouragement from the way they
played the chiefs this past week
it was it was work been like from
patrick mahomes and this offense and
it's it's something to see when when
they can you know we've seen the
explosion days where they just go off
and the home stoves for 400 plus yards
and tyree kill goes for 200 plus and
they get the ball going down the field
to kelsey and all the things they can do
but when they can win a grind it out
kind of game like this that's what you
have to do come late january football on
these super bowl runs and now that
you've seen they can win both of those
ways it seems like the last few weeks
we've seen kansas city really be able to
grind out those wins that's just
championship dna that's what you'd
expect from an andy reed coach team uh
speaking of championship tna yeah yeah
go ahead jack can i ask you one i want
to ask you one question because this is
something that coach dungey chris sims
and i we talk about and they look at the
chiefs and every week they get so mad i
wish you were in the viewing room with
us they're yelling and screaming because
they think the chiefs get too cute at
times but you know that's andy reeves
personality and he says why are they
struggling see to me
i don't question that to me i look at
him and saying you know what these guys
are winning in so many different ways
they're preparing themselves for a nice
playoff run and what they feel to
realize is when you're going for
back-to-back titles
people you're going to get people's best
shot every single week you know what i'm
saying like they're going to come out
and you're everybody super bowl you're
everybody's playoff game and to me it
just seems like i'm not worried about
the way the chiefs look
i just know that each experience is just
you know just more wealth of knowledge
going into the playoffs and i think
that's going to help them what do you
think
well i continue to be a little bit more
of a believer in their defense and if
they can just get a handful of stops you
always know that their offense is going
to take over this defense just shows up
in those special moments they do just
enough to get a handful of stops and is
you know i said workman like on the
offensive side of the ball but the way
that this defense went after
you know sean payton he always comes
into these games with the perfect game
plan and he has ways to scheme guys
completely wide open down the field and
all of those little crossing routes and
all of those little screens and all the
dump off stuff that they were playing to
camara the way that they were just such
in the face of i really think they wrote
the book a little bit here we've been
saying this all year on this show riding
get up on those short routes that is the
bread and butter option 1a on every
single play for the saints offense is to
dump it down to camara and let him go
one-on-one in the open field and go
dominate people and nobody all year long
has taken that away except for kansas
city so the fact that they're showing a
little life on the defensive side of the
ball to go along with everything that
we're talking about with mahomes and the
offense lets me know this this is by far
in my opinion you give me the field or
you give me kansas city it's a
no-brainer i'm taking kansas city let's
flip it to the new england patriots
miami pizza is so weird to see miami
just run the ball all over a bill
belichick coach defense is this more
about the direction that the patriots
are going or more about the direction
that miami is going as they rise with
two of play quarterback well well what
i'm going to do is i'm going to focus on
the miami dolphins and that was the big
question that i had for the mommy
dolphins and blind brian flores could
they consistently run the football we
know they have a really good defense we
know they have a young quarterback who's
somewhat of a game manager we both agree
about that
but it was more about the run game and
their inability to run this year and his
commitment to running the football
against his mentor bill belichick i was
so thoroughly impressed and i just think
that it's a such a positive thing
because it creates a mindset it's a
mentality hey we're going to run the
football no we're not going to drop back
and pass that's the easy thing to do
we're going to line up we're going to
strap up our chin straps and we're gonna
show everybody that we're not gonna be a
one-dimensional team going into the
playoffs and if you're a one-dimensional
team with a rookie quarterback that's a
game manager you're one and done in the
playoffs and i think that brian flores
is gonna try to build off this jack and
continue right on into the playoffs i
think he's done a great job though
it feels like every year of my life the
new england patriots have been in the
playoffs they've been that one sneaky
team that nobody wants to play come
january and now they're not going to be
there they're not going to be in the
patriots so here was your former coach
coach belichick really the greatest ever
do in my mind on missing the playoffs
this year
with this loss you guys were eliminated
from playoff contention first time since
08 just wondering your reaction to that
[Music]
disappointed but we we didn't deserve to
win today so
and really that's that's the reality of
the patriots and i'm really excited for
the patriots because yeah it's
disappointing this year but you have a
chance to rebuild they've dominated
we've seen that for almost two decades
they've done their thing but they have
an opportunity and it's going to start
at the quarterback position and coach
belichick he's going to have to decide
before jack i was all in on cam
cam noon give him opportunity he's going
to do the right thing he's going to be
mature he's got he's going to play well
and when i saw him yesterday once again
dropping back throwing the ball right
into the ground i'm like why can't he
complete a pass without throwing it into
the ground so i think i think
belichick's gonna have to really get on
his on his horse and get these guys um
bring some more talent in and figure out
where the quarterback position is going
because kim is not the answer as much as
i love him
he's not the answer there's no way
you're going to pay him they got him on
such a discount for this season there's
no way that you would then pay them
after the way that this year has played
out really a lot of the offensive
struggles that they've seen has been a
result of an inability to throw the ball
they just really never trusted him from
the pocket at all so it became a whole
bunch of gimmicky runs and short passes
and reverses and read option stuff
whatever their power runs with the
quarterback anything they could do to
make it feel ecology and creative but it
just wasn't enough to win on a
consistent basis
if you were gm belichick right now what
would be order of operations number one
because it's been such a strange year
first you had brady leave then all the
coveted opt-outs that they had they had
more covert opt-outs than any other team
that we saw around the league and
everybody's going it's gonna be fine
belichick will figure it out
this guy's not a huge deal
for them to lose and he's not a huge
dealer but it turns out that all of this
stuff just added up on top of each other
before you know it they're sitting here
in a position where they're missing the
playoffs was still two weeks remaining
so what would you do what would be order
of operations one two three if you will
if you are running the new england
patriots right now as belichick
well obviously first we have to sit down
and we have to check out the salary cap
and how much you know how much we have
on the salary cap but my first order of
business would probably be right now at
this point in time is to give jared
stenham an opportunity i don't care how
he looks in practice you drafted him
give him my opportunity to go out there
and play and see what he can do real
live fire hey cam newton had his
opportunity coach you've been very
patient with him it's time to move
forward that would be the first thing
the second thing would be
um
i'm not sure what the second thing would
be because i believe if you if you
figure out the quarterback situation
everything else will fall in place but
you got to figure out the salary cap get
get more weapons um for the quarterback
to be able to throw to and some of these
veterans that are making a lot of money
you might have to go tap them on the
shoulder and he's like hey we need you
to take a pay cut or we're going to have
to move in a different direction because
they have some young talent it's just
going to take a bit to kind of develop
them
i think they could do something crazy at
the quarterback position i i don't know
what specifically that is maybe i'm
trying to get i guess
that that's that's really where i'm
leading a staffer to sam darnold
somebody that another team has given up
on you know what i'm saying no no i
don't know that i'm totally dead on sam
darwin yet that whole franchise we'll
get into that but that old franchise is
such a dumpster fire from the top down
it's hard for me to pin it on one player
particularly a young player they really
never got a chance to come in and learn
is just like just thrown into the trash
i don't know that i'm done with him yet
and then i'm just watching the jets play
yesterday and watching darno find a
little bit of a rhythm i just i don't
know if i'm writing him off you give him
the right coaching you give him josh
mcdaniels who knows what his future
could look like same goes for stafford
though
and that's an excellent point and i say
and i shook my head no because i know
the jets aren't dumb enough to trade him
within the division and what pick was he
he was the first second round second
pick overall very high yep yeah top two
three pick or whatever it was i don't
think they're dumb enough to trade them
to coach belichick and josh mcdaniels
because josh could have sam donald right
and belichick will provide a good
defense a good um special teams unit and
some more weapons so as much as the
patriots look down and out right now you
better believe they did the same thing
after 2002 after winning the super bowl
they were down and out they didn't make
the playoffs nine and seven i think it
was or eight and eight and then he went
out and got some free agents got me had
a good draft and all of a sudden you win
the super bowl in o3 you win the super
bowl four and then there there it goes
yeah he was the third third overall pick
darnold was and i'm with you when you
watched the patriots play this year it
didn't matter if it was kim dude it
really didn't matter what quarterback it
was there was a reason from a weapons
standpoint that brady said there's
there's just i gotta i gotta get out of
here and he went to tampa who was super
talent heavy at the wide receiver
position brings gronk along with him and
then goes out and gets three whatever
three running backs through free
agencies it starts bringing in guys and
recruiting throughout this whole process
so it's just a team that that missed on
nikhil harry and hasn't been able to
figure their way out into talent ever
since then let's get to a number one
overall pick though kyler murray how
much fun was this game to watch
yesterday the eagles hurts kyler murray
on the field at the same time it went
all the way down to the wire you got the
feeling that these are two quarterbacks
you're gonna be around the nfl for a
long long time who was the most
impressive as you sat down and watched
this game yesterday
well who was the most impressive i would
say jalen hurts was probably the most
impressive and colin murray was
absolutely outstanding but i'm talking
about a guy his second start with you
know coming off coming off a heck of a
game he comes back and he plays
extremely well and the key that i want
you to watch is the zero interception 63
yards rushing it's something about jalen
hurts the leadership the feel for the
pocket just his knowledge the instincts
everything that he does it just looks
better than carson wins it flows better
it's smoother and these guys are playing
at a high high level because of jalen
hurts and his humility and his work
ethic and his mindset and the way he
celebrates and interacts with the other
players
they got issues with carson wentz
because there's no way carson wentz is
going to get his starting job back
carson wentz is another one of those
quarterbacks that's going to be bouncing
around and who's going to have interest
in carson it's like could a carson wentz
ever end up at a place like new england
you know what i mean like i think those
are the kind of names not the tie two
conversations together but the tie two
conversations together i think new
england's gonna be looking for one of
those sort of names and for carson wentz
that would be best case scenario across
the board but back to the this game
yesterday every time i watch kyler
murray his ability to just dismantle a
pass rush solely with his legs and
sometimes he runs to run but a lot of
times he runs to bootleg and throw on
the run and he throws more accurately
than i feel like anybody i see he's
moving i mean you know how quick he is
he is flying and then he just throws the
ball in a pee and it's right on the
money and sometimes he'll reset his feet
and he got to that second throwing
location so fast that he still has two
or three seconds to set his feet look
around and go hit somebody
and then you put this arizona pass rush
they just destroyed daniel jones a week
ago you remember summer assan reddick
with those five sacks then they come
back this week and go get another six
sacks against the mobile quarterback so
the combination of tyler murray this
offense and with this pack
arizona becoming a bit of a dangerous
team lingering right there in that wild
card spot
yeah you look you look at larry
fitzgerald coming back he made a few
catches and i think the biggest
difference in the offense was deandre
hopkins making big plays down the field
colin murray is a different quarterback
when they're connecting down the field
um obviously the run game you got dan
arnold max williams you know the tight
ends catching passes and things like
that but i was really impressed with um
kyle murray because he didn't have a lot
of yards rushing but he was still
patient enough to get outside the pocket
and not just take off but continue to
throw the ball and i mean for over 400
yards passing that against the eagles a
really good eagles front and a eagles
defense that plays extremely hard i was
impressed with kyla murray so when you
ask me who was i'm more impressed with
of course it has to be jalen hurts
because he's making his second start
yeah i'm with you and he looks he
already looks so much better than
winston he has zero experience playing
in this league and deandre hopkins this
is the first year of those two working
together it's going to be the biggest
year of deandre hopkins career i mean
think about that it's not like he never
had a quarterback he was working with
watson there for a couple of years but i
mean this has just been an instant
connection that's taken off and i think
we'd be remiss if we didn't mention a
little bit of the special teams
yesterday with arizona too they blocked
that punt which was a massive play in
the game and then also the fake punt
that's the one that i'm drawn to that
punter just like he's like you're about
to drop his foot on that thing and that
full back releases right up the field
that putter just put a dime right over
the shoulder for that and that was a
huge first down so for them to go win
that game that game was super tight
right there at the end you remember
those plays
hey i gotta ask you a question now do
you have any problem with carson wentz
putting out there that he doesn't want
to be a backup and
that you know he he he can't see himself
as a backup or should he
just shut up he had his opportunity and
just support the quarterback that's in
front of him because that's what jalen
hurts ultimately did when he was when um
carson wentz was the starting
quarterback he supported him and now all
of a sudden you see carson wentz and his
camp leaking information to the media
saying that he doesn't want to be a
backup i have a problem with that
because this is not the time especially
when you're in a fight to try to win a
division
always tricky situation i mean first and
foremost he should 100 support
jalen hurst i think that from that
standpoint it's a no-brainer but you can
see our quarterback who's making over
100 million dollars and was signed to be
the franchise guy and you know really
started that super bowl run that was
ultimately finished out by the back up
quarterback coming in in fols
would feel like he's a starter i mean
you can see all of those things and
in all likelihood he probably still does
have the skill set to be that i know
this year has really been rough across
the board for wentz but given that
they're still in it you have to get
behind you have to get behind hertz i
mean you just have to as a teammate as a
man that defines character right there
and and my guess is based on everything
i know about wence and everybody i've
talked to about wence he will do that he
will fall into line and i never want to
blow out of proportion anything that
somebody in his camp or whatever could
have leaked the media because it's hard
to know what's real what's not real we
got it we got a few tmz type people in
the nfl business too and this very well
could be one of those uh so let's let's
get to uh the jets the jets and the rams
the jets figure out a way to get a win
we'll start with sean mcveigh this is
sean mcvay because from the ram side a
complete disaster from the jet side of
miracle let's start with the disaster
here's mcvay after the loss
i've got to do a better job getting us
ready to go gary and and really it was
in all three phases it wasn't good
enough um this loss will demoralize us
only as much as we allow it to it's
going to be embarrassing sick to your
stomach about it
but we do have two games left and we've
got to find a way to respond and rebound
on a short week you know not really a
short week but but this week um as we
get ready for the seahawks but that was
a very humbling and it's going to be
humbling but uh we're going to move
forward and uh that's exactly what we'll
do that's all i know how to do
you know and i respect sean mcvay for
coming out and saying that because it
was his fault because he didn't have his
team ready um to play we saw it against
the dolphins we saw it against the jets
we saw it in two losses against san
francisco this team when they're focused
and they're and let me just say this
when i watched them play
i didn't see that passion i did not see
that same passion that energy that they
play with i just i didn't see it i just
think they they felt like okay let's fly
out here let's play well let's play
against the jets let's beat them and you
know let's just make sure we get out
healthy and look forward to our next
week's game you can't do that you can't
look past a team and for sean mcvay to
have his team not prepared and to lose
to a winless team
when you're trying to gain momentum
heading into the playoffs and jared goff
looks uh he looked terrible like are you
kidding me this is the way you look so
to me if the jets if i mean i'm sorry if
they can't run the football use the
play-action boots get outside the pocket
and he have those easy completions it
seems like they struggle jack
yeah i don't i don't know where i don't
know where for the rams they just kind
of had a year like this where they where
they look awesome some weeks and they
just look awful other weeks and it
doesn't seem like there's much in the
middle and i don't know if you're going
to put all that on mcvay if you want to
put that on golf you want to put that on
the team as a whole but it's been the
kind of year that they have had uh and
mcveigh's the kind of coach that will
just shoulder all of that and i think
it's why so many players love him the
way that they do right you include it
it's just it's what great coaches do is
they shoulder all of that now on the jet
side of this thing
they didn't really winning this is not a
good thing for the franchise i mean it's
just it's this does not benefit the
franchise and i understand the people in
that building they don't care but it's
not like there's some massive motivation
for them to go win football games right
now this should have been just a stomp
on the jet scenario and instead
who knows maybe sam darden winds up
making this job
let me jump in and just say this
as a player i played on a one in 15 team
and when we won our first game it was
against kansas city and we celebrated
like the super bowl because jack i'll
tell you this you never want to be that
guy and this is going to stick with you
the rest of your life you're going to
always be associated with
you're on an 016 team
it's just no different than me i'm
always going to be associated with a
helmet catch i own that okay
but you never want to be on an on-16
team and those guys they're professional
athletes they're getting paid a lot of
money on the jets but they still have a
lot of pride and you cannot tell me to
go out there and lose a freaking game
for a kid that's in college
a kid that's in college that's not even
guaranteed that he may want to come to
the jets
if adam gates is still coaching the jets
if i'm trevor lawrence there's no way
i'm going to the jets absolutely not so
you want us to not play football
and basically quit and lose the game on
purpose to go get a uh un unknown
commodity no how many times have we seen
these kids come in first pick second
pick third pick and struggle look at
mitchell trubisky look at sam darnold
look at the inconsistencies of those
guys so no you don't want to be part of
a team on 16 team and i commend the jets
those young men for going out there
playing so hard winning a football game
i totally hear you i totally hear that
he's not a perfect prospect there's no
such thing as a perfect prospect but
he's pretty damn close talking about
trevor lawrence he's he's no mister
biscuit and and there's it's not going
to be a long time before somebody else
comes around like trevor lawrence the
jets are going to be able to pick look
how happy they are jack look how happy
they are brother look it's rightfully so
man and right there look at trevor
lawrence down there in the front he's
dressed up like with that leprechaun
here we go even if it's not the
leprechaun act like this
uh after the way he beat the irish this
weekend uh but but trevor lawrence man i
you know i think he would be much more
likely and we've discussed this a bit i
think he'd be much more likely to go to
jacksonville than i do with the new york
jets he's from the south
i really i just think it's going to be
hard to convince you ever been to
clemson south carolina that is a unique
place in the world now
i have not but um i've driven past it on
my way to university of south carolina
where my daughter used to go yeah yeah
it's just a unique place in the world i
mean it's deep south
and i just think that that jacksonville
environment would be more similar to
what he's used to than going up and
being in the city especially with the
jets i just don't see him fitting in the
jets building and ultimately what i
think he would have done is going back
you understand his best friends are dabo
sweeney's kids right so all he does is
spend time around davos c 24 7. so
nobody has his ear like dabo sweeney and
my guess is that dabo has been planting
little seeds about can you imagine if
you were the winningest quarterback you
imagine if you won a heisman trophy here
at clemson imaginable you'll get another
national championship about travis
etienne he could have been a first round
trap but he goes back to clemson all
these assistant coaches over the years
they couldn't have a head coaching job
their head coaches out there they go
back to clemson that is the environment
that is the standard down there and
honestly let me just say this
let me just say this you know this is a
business
and you think about
if he goes to jacksonville and i don't
care if he starts a no
it's jacksonville nobody cares
you're in new york
now to me you win the heisman you go to
new york you turn this ship around all
of a sudden you're four and 12 and then
eight and eight and then ten and six and
twelve and four
you turn this thing around to me that's
when i'm really thoroughly impressed
but from a business standpoint the type
of money that he could stand to make in
new york and become basically the king
of new york if he turns this thing
around compared to going to jacksonville
i don't know as long as adam gates is
not my head coach i wouldn't mind going
to the jets and playing in new york and
playing against belichick and playing
against josh allen that's what i would
want to do that's just that's just me
personally
miami's getting pretty damn good too
that that could be you gotta hang on
you gotta expect that new england's
gonna turn it around quickly i mean if
they figure it's just belichick at some
point belichick is gonna find somebody
at the quarterback position he can win
with their skill position's gonna get
better and they're gonna play great
defense so new england whether it's one
year two years whatever the case would
be they're going to be back
the bills may very well make it to the
super bowl this year i mean that like
the way josh allen's playing right now
he could be the mvp he has just been off
the charts the way he's playing lately
uh in mcdermott the way he has the
defense rolling stefan diggs coming in i
mean this is a really tough and two is
only going to get better so this is
really a great division that he would be
going into
i think the way that you should do it if
you do want trevor lawrence to come to
the jets is involve them in all the
decisions hey we're moving on from gays
what kind of a coach do you think you'd
click well with who would be perfect
what like i think if you took that
approach and maybe do it through dabo
involve though who would be what if it
was dabo
what if it was dabo why why couldn't you
offer him 15 million a year to come
why not
you could right
is that crazy
now you're getting into the fun stuff
there and i think i think you could the
problem is right now in college football
the rich get richer and richer and
richer and there's nobody richer than
dabo swinney other than maybe saban it's
pretty easy to win i mean it's not very
hard to go beat the acc when you have
the kind of talent that dabo swinney has
so he kind of rolls through that
schedule every year and then just has to
win you know two tough games down the
stretch you go play in the afc east like
we're saying that's a whole different
that's a whole different ball game come
to fall
well i mean do you like do you think
he's willing to sacrifice that or his
situation is just so sweet in college
with the private planes and everything's
paid for and he's the king of of clemson
yeah you're right just stay here
i i don't know that it's impossible to
talk about it but having trevor lawrence
in the relationship that i know those
two have would be an added benefit and i
mean he could win in the nfl i have no
doubt he clicks with players like few
coaches that i've seen he could win
anywhere
think about all the young players think
think about all the young players from
alabama just all across the country that
they have so much respect for dabo you
know so he knows most of these young
guys coming so to me if i'm the jets man
i'm opening up the if if if you give
adam gates a head coaching job matter of
fact two head coaching jobs one with the
dolphins and one with the jets
i would break the bank to get doppel
sweeney that just him as a man his
influence what he stands for his energy
and his ability like you said to get
players to play for him
just a thought
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports